Okay, let's try one last interesting pedigree before wrapping
up here. We're going to turn our focus to the sometimes
ignored mitochondrial DNA and look at an inheritance pattern
that's referred to as maternal inheritance. And it's maternal because
it's inherited via the mitochondrial DNA. So based on
just that information alone, I want to see if you
can tell me, which children would be affected. All of
these with the question marks here, I haven't told you,
if they're going to be affected or not. Based
on all the information you see here, and knowing that
this is a maternal inheritance pattern, I want you
to check the boxes for which children would be affected.